hey everybody welcome back to therm
learning my name is Heinrich and it's
great that all of you and they are ready
to watch my second video on this channel
I'm still super excited to have done
this at all and be able to share my
experience with you my experiences from
my background in business and management
so I thought long and hard about what
could be a good topic for this video and
I think one thing that many many many
new joiners and business struggle with
is behavior in meetings and what do I
mean by that what you can imagine most
corporations we have many many meetings
every day you probably meet with your
team leave them with other colleagues
from other departments you sit together
to discuss topics and make advancements
in the projects that you're pursuing and
to basically collect input from other
people you are working with and recently
a more junior colleague at my workplace
approached me and asked me about
specific Eva's topic he told me I'm like
you know I'm sitting in these meetings
very often I do not know what to say is
the right thing for me as a junior
colleague to say anything at all should
I just be there listen to the others
what is my role what am I expected to do
as a junior colleague in these meetings
and I could just very much relate to
that I clearly remember when I was a
rookie in consulting and I was sitting
in these first meetings with some senior
clients
I fed highly intimidated you're very
often not sitting there alone but then
there is your your your project you eat
your engagement manager there's a
partner from your consulting firm their
frequent leader might also be a junior
partner and then a whole bunch of
clients and then there was of course me
as well I know the junior consultant
knew on the team a rookie and I just
didn't have a clue what okay and I think
this is just the normal reaction that
many people have when they are facing
these kinds of situations so reflecting
on that experience and looking back I
think there are three tips that I would
like to share with you what you as a
junior colleague actually can do to have
a positive contribution to the meeting
and also to be perceived as a
professional
the first tip I'd like to give you is to
really clarify with your team lead what
your role is go to him and ask him okay
we're having this meeting I see that I
am part of the list of participants what
do you expect me to do what is your role
what what shall I do right and one role
could be that you will moderate you will
lead through the meetings will lead the
agenda you will call out the different
topics make sure that the time is kept
that you are covering all the topics you
want to discuss in the meeting make sure
that you get the contributions from
everybody in the room and really step up
by just doing a moderation a kind of
work this could be one role but
frequently this role is more for the
more senior people in the room usually
be organized that the person who has
invited to the meeting he will usually
like to take charge of the meeting and
be able to do exactly this and just
moderate the whole conversation so what
can you do and my second tip actually
would be that you can be the number guy
right you can be the guy who knows all
the facts and figures about the topics
that you are discussing in the room and
this can relate to many many things so
imagine you're in a sales meeting you're
discussing how are the different clients
going maybe your key account manager and
talking about all these things and
suddenly a question pops up for instance
when what revenue that we did last year
in asia-pacific or North America or in
Europe with this client right or what is
the revenue of this country entity or
the stoker entity what are these people
doing this one and frequently these
kinds of questions are not directly
being answered by people in the room
people don't know the numbers by heart
maybe even though they're slow but not
everybody does and then basically
everybody saying okay yeah let's move on
and here you can be the guy who just in
advance prepares all these numbers has
numbers like that at hand and then can
just sweep them out and this is
something that you as a junior colleague
can do because very often you're sitting
on the data you're doing the data
analysis are working in Excel are
crunching the numbers so you had the
source of all these things and and make
of death this is the power we have that
many people don't have and don't do
because they're just further away from
the numbers not caring that much as you
can care so make use of that advantage
that you have there and this goes
further than just having the numbers at
hand often they're questions which you
will not be able to answer right away
and also you cannot have all the
information out there available prepared
in advance before the meeting but you
can be the one who looks it up right if
does the question come up search for it
look into your systems look into your
information systems just pour the data
get a doubt present it to the rest of
the team because this is then really a
venue that you can add to the
conversation by adding data and then
being able to directly pick up the
discussion where this question was being
asked instead of somebody who needs to
go back and then maybe later he can
contribute or distribute the information
to the group my third tip would be to
always push for clear next steps and
implications that come out of the
meeting we all have been in these
meetings where after hours and hours of
discussion actually nothing is really
clear nothing has been decided it feels
like a complete waste of time to
everybody so what can you as a junior
colleague do in order to improve that
experience for everybody well first
thing is clarify what the objective is
before I even walk into the meeting talk
to your team need talk to the meeting
organizer that is feasible and ask him
what do we actually want to take out of
the meeting and if you feel that
especially towards the end there's no
clear objective nor clear result towards
that goal that you want to achieve make
sure that actions are being taken right
sit together and really ask to each in
the room okay what are the things now
that we want to do what are the next
steps maybe walk up front go to a
flipchart write down what the next steps
are that are supposed to come out of
there ask the very simple question who
is supposed to do what until when and
really make sure that this is clear and
everybody is on the same page for that
because this is just the basics that
just need to be there after meeting for
two heaven had
any venue at all if this is not there
and was just a waste of time for
everybody and if other colleagues do not
understand this I do not see this in the
moment but you do then for the sake of
everybody step up and make sure that
these things are being clarified and
done of course here you need to be
careful for office politics depending on
the situation that you are in it might
be that this might seem inappropriate to
do as a junior colleague so here always
also ask your teamily for other
colleagues for feedback or maybe in the
very beginning observe or other people
are behaving just to make sure that you
do not break the kind of more implicit
rules of the organization's how
different people are supposed to behave
especially based on tenure and just what
the expectations of the other people are
to not be basically seen as an idiot by
the colleagues or just being seen as
rude this of course you should avoid so
yeah I think three neat tips that are
really crucial and important for you to
be successful in meetings as a junior
colleague first clarify your role
beforehand second in the meeting if
there is not another row that you are
assigned to be the number guy be sure
that you inform and distribute a
disseminate all information that is
there in all the formation that is been
asked for in the meeting and third for
the sake of everybody involved make sure
that the meeting has a reside if you do
this I trust you would be perceived as a
colleague or really adds value to the
meeting and I trust this is the
experience that you would make as well
so keep learning thank you for looking
at this channel please subscribe if you
haven't done that so far
this would really mean a lot to me as
somebody who just starts off with the
channel to see that you're actually
enjoying it and you are ready and only
waiting for new videos so I will do very
soon thank you